I can't remember forever she was current
Sandra yeah what do you have for
breakfast
no no what did you have for breakfast
favorite programming language oh it's a
scope of course favorite BBC basic
because I learnt it when I was six or
seven years old a primary school and
it's the only one overly learned so
stylistically java is probably my
favorite I used that for many years but
now I'm mostly is Python but I'm not
quite as competent as I'd like to be
with it favorite poorly PHP well beste
it's messy
- like obvious obviously no like I've
been using Python for a it was not the
first like real language that I ever
properly started using in like 2007
something like that posed in fairly
early on Python and it's now how I think
to the point where I can't actually
write pseudocode if I try to write
pseudocode I write Python by accident
best language best syntax anyway
oh my favorite oh my new favorite
programming language is Python because
you you can do really anything with it
it's yeah it's pretty amazing I don't
know about favorite they will have their
pros and cons I work a lot with
JavaScript language C C Python PHP C
yeah mainly yeah you program at all a
little bit yeah - so you stopped with a
Windows PC or what Apple Beck no not
anymore or sadly or happily no sadly I
don't know favorite programming
languages fourth although our College
you program really very much but that's
the one that I like the most so what is
your favorite programming language
probably PHP favorite programming
language I you know I have said in the
past that if I remember runed on a
desert island I would prefer to have see
if I think about what I program on a day
to day basis I probably most often use
awk and
I often use Python for things where awk
isn't big enough you know it doesn't
scale up to bigger things and after that
it's kind of a toss-up javascript not
the only one though we've had a few of
those what's the reason for that why do
you like it so it's just like I used to
hate it it was just then I did an
internship doing front-end web
development and I actually really really
like it now and using like the newer
versions like es6 and that's that I
really enjoy it
what is your favorite programming
language on what common lisp
because I can do anything I want in it
can you tell me what your favorite
programming language is and tell me why
well quite like Lisp but I don't know
why it's a bit stupid I end up doing a
little MATLAB and I don't want to like
MATLAB but it's just incredibly useful
so what is your favorite programming
language well I think the better
question is if you could only take one
programming language to a desert island
what would it be
I'm guessing it's gonna be seek oh yes
I'm in total agreement we but I don't
totally agree why about every single
thing I really don't but we're I'm with
him on that one you know if you're told
there's one and only one it's got to be
able to do low level and it's harder to
do high level object-oriented stuff in C
but you can do it if you want to it
would have to be C which is your
favorite programming language anyway
favorite programming language at the
moment the program I'm running a lot in
it 6502 assembler I wouldn't say it's my
favorite my favorite programming
language for I guess it's JavaScript in
the moment it's just you do so much of
it it's hard to know if I using the
other ones what's your favorite
programming language I'm basic obviously
because it's basic and people can
understand it more importantly kids can
understand it that's why I love it
I could understand it as a kid got
scripts with it program in other
languages from there on but from here my
point of view of the museum it's just a
great language for kids to get involved
with and if they like it move on from
there what is your favorite programming
language and why what do you use most
gosh I mean the last stuff I was writing
was in a mill filter and XM which is
probably not something you've ever heard
of that's new to me what was it's it's a
language put together by a guy here who
wrote a mail system that we still kind
of use very recondite obscure and local
but but basic basically I kids and
grandkids etc to use Python do you
program at all
yes I mean a lot of the project involved
programming and image processing what's
your favorite programming language well
to be honest I maybe I'm mostly used to
using MATLAB and I used that a lot in
this project to integrate all bits and
pieces programming languages 68000
assembler because for the sega megadrive
it's a native language for it favorite
programming language and why it's
getting more difficult actually I think
but I still like c-sharp the best I
think that if your poem in Windows which
of course not everyone is and people
need to be versatile in programming
windows it's much easier to get user
interface up and running in c-sharp it's
got loads of libraries and it's also a
statically typed language which I like
oh my favorite programming language
I'll call with probably an unusual one
which is love you it's a graphical
programming language it's actually
called G the thing that drives it is
called G which I absolutely despised
when I first started off but it's trying
to get to grips with it but love it now
so yeah good what do you do what do you
do in it just so it's busy you have
icons so you have a fun panel and a
block diagram so it's like a circuit
diagram which is maybe why it appeals so
for example you would have a graph let's
say you dragged a graph and that will
give you an icon a graph icon and then
let's say you had a signal so you would
on here you'd have something that
acquires the signal that you know
connects to a data acquisition card then
you would feed that into the graph and
then the signal would appear but then
you have a whole palette of different
tools like Fourier transform spectrum
analyzers that you can apply so but you
can also do for loops while loops
conditional statements or it's it's and
what you have to think about is not some
what's the functions but the data flow
which is different way of thinking so
yeah it's it's both that it's that
deeply engrained in how I think but it's
also that meat and like parsimonious or
syntax yeah Python is wonderful
parsimonious parsing I know parsimonious
is that actually literally a Cody oh
yeah it's good fun actually accidental
pun